willkommen zur heutigen
Vorlesung heute
gibt es wie immer sie ahnen es schon
wiederhole mich sie Merkens heute gibt
es wieder ein Einblick in das
begriffsnetz und dieses begriffsnetz
wird immer dichter es wird tragfähig es
wird ein
doppelter Boden der einen aufhängt wenn
man in der Klausur gerade nicht weiter
weiß dann kommt einem natürlich sofort
hier dieses begriffsnetz in den Sinn
links rechts oben unten Orientierung
Gegensätze Bezüge
ergeben sich hier natürlich nicht in
Stein gemeißelt alles ist wie sie
mittlerweile wissen der Philosophie
flexibel was aber nicht heißt dass es
beliebig ist man kann natürlich immer
gewisse Konstellation von Begriffen
kritisieren muss natürlich konstruktiv
dann sagen wie ist denn bitteschön
anders sein sollte und was damit
gewonnen ist so sieht es in der
Philosophie aus es ist letztendlich ein
komplexes Begriffs ich sag nicht Begriff
Spiel aber eine Begriff Diskussion die
aber natürlich nicht nur sich im
Elfenbeinturm vollziehen soll sondern
die im Idealfall zu guten zwingenden
Gründen führt wie es Jürgen habermaß
sagen würde sagen trifft die gegründe
und die Leiden unser Handeln und führen
dazu dass die Welt besser wird im ideal
jedenfalls und dann haben wir hier jetzt
noch
verschiedene weitere Begriffe hier
kennengelernt
und ich möchte jetzt einfach heute
noch mal ein bisschen auf das Thema
Zurechenbarkeit eingehen das ist hier
oben joint commitment und den Rückblick
geben auf
die Frage ob es am moralische oder nicht
moralische Handlungen gibt da möchte ich
noch mal ansetzen in meinem Rückblick
wir hatten ja Unterschieden es gibt die
Moralität es gibt die Immoralität und es
gibt die Amoralität oder Amoral oder
nicht Moralität finde ich eigentlich
besser weil häufig wenn man sagt das ist
amoralisch dann würden bestimmt 50%
aller Menschen auf der Straße sagen das
ist gleichbedeutend wie unmoralisch
gibt ja auch das Wort asozial was man
nicht mehr so häufig verwendet
vielleicht das guten Gründen weil es
diskriminierend ist aber auch sozial
würde ja bedeuten nicht sonderlich
sozial also eher negativ und genauso
könnte man jetzt meinen armoralisch sei
auch irgendwie nicht moralisch ist
bedeutet auch nicht moralisch aber nicht
im Sinne des Unmoral sie merken die das
Wort nicht Moral praktisch ist
mindestens doppeldeutig ja es kann
bedeuten es negiert irgendwelche
moralischen Prinzipien es kann aber auch
bedeuten es ist überhaupt nicht
moralisch zu qualifizieren es wäre ein
Kategorienfehler wenn ich von etwas in
einer moralischen Hinsicht sprechen
würde was eigentlich moralisch ist
hingegen wenn ich über etwas sage es ist
nicht moralisch oder
unmoralisch besser es ist unmoralisch
dann befinde ich mich gerade in
moralischen Kontext in normativen
Kontexten und kritisier was normativ das
kann ich nicht tun wenn nicht sage was
ist amoralisch weil ich damit dann sage
dass diese Sache dieser Sachverhalt oder
was auch immer über was wir auch immer
sprechen dass der überhaupt nicht sich
hin zumindest moralisch normativen
Kontexten befindet und darüber moralisch
zu sprechen wäre wie gesagt ein
Kategorienfehler das wäre so wenn ich
sagen würde oh heute ist der Bodensee
aber hungrig
könnte ich metaphorisch sagen dass wir
dann gleichbedeutend wie heute will der
Bodensee möglichst viele Menschen
ertränken aber das möchte ertränken ist
eine andere Frage aber heute möchte
viele Menschen verschlucken weil er so
hungrig ist man kann dann metaphorisch
sprechen also Kategorienfehler lassen
sich häufig mit der vorgesteuerten
uneigentliche Rede gibt es ein
terziumkomparation ist also eine
Schnittmenge der Bedeutung von hungrig
und verschlingen ist ja auch eine
Metapher an und Tosen oder gefährlich
Strömung oder was immer und so kann man
dann noch sind raus gewinnen aber man
kann natürlich Kategorienfehler auch so
begehen dass man selbst in einer
metaphorischen Rede nicht mehr draus
gewinnen würde sie können sich beliebige
Prädikate überlegen die man auf den
Bodensee anwenden kann der Bodensee ist
heute eifersüchtig der Bodensee ist
heute
normativ moralischen Kontexten situiert
und jetzt möchte ich Ihnen im Sinne
einer
erweiterten Wiederholung nicht einer
bloßen bloßen Wiederholungen
weiterführenden Wiederholung da mal ein
Vorschlag bringen nämlich das Phänomen
des Spiels oder des Spielens Spiele oder
spielen ist doppeldeutig wenn man
spricht man ja von einem Spiel
verschiedene Hinsicht sie kennen
vielleicht von Wittgenstein das
Sprachspiel also Wittgenstein sagt Spiel
ist so ein vieldeutiges Wort da kann man
nur von sprach Spielen sprechen also
welche Bedeutung hat es die Folien
finden Sie auch alle mittlerweile auf
Ilias meines Wissens habe ich jetzt kurz
vorher hochgeladen also man kann
verschiedene Spiele sich vorstellen man
kann sich vorstellen ich denke natürlich
sofort an Computerspiele aber wenn sie
z.B das Wort Computerspiel hören
dann denken sie wahrscheinlich oder ich
denke dann dran ein Produkt
Computerspiel was ich mir kaufen kann
aber es hat auch noch die Bedeutung dass
es ein Medium ist nicht nur
Unterhaltungsmedium sondern das damit
eine Aktivität angeht nämlich das spiele
ein Computerspiel hat gewisse Regeln
klare wird es natürlich bei
irgendwelchen
Gesellschaftsspielen nehmen wir mal ein
Fußball ein Fußballspiel
kann ich mir im Fernsehen anschauen kann
ich konsumieren als Medium ich kann mir
ein Fußballspiel aufzeichnen ich kann
dafür bezahlen ja wenn ich sie anschauen
möchte wenn sein tolles Spiel ist also
im Fernsehen ich kann aber auch ein
Fußballspiel betrachten ja aber ich kann
natürlich auch selbst Fußball spielen
und hier geht's jetzt und die zweite
Bedeutung nicht das hätte es Medium oder
Spiel als Objekt oder sowas sondern
Spieler als Praxis als Regel geleitete
Praxis an der wir partizipieren können
und jetzt möchte ich Ihnen einen Zitat
Vorlesen auf Englisch was von einem
Bekannten niederländischen
Kulturwissenschaftler stammt mit dem
Titel homol oder also der menschliche
Spieler der Spieler der Mensch als
Spieler der Spielende Mensch da gibt es
verschiedene Angriff Formulierungen es
gibt den homorides das ist der lachende
Mensch und so weiter und so fort aber
das ist jetzt der Spielende Mensch und
jetzt sagt diese Autor folgendes play
live outside the system and folly and
equally outside those of truth and fallt
good and evil Aussage activity
it has no more function the valuations
of weißen virgit App hier also wir
können hier keine moralischen Kategorien
anwenden keine normativen also weiß und
welche also laste und Tugend oder auch
sowas wie war und falsch
ist ja auch irgendwie schwach normativ
war und falsch es ist ja an dem Ideal
gemessen das entspricht dem Ideal das
weicht ab also ich würde sagen baut
falsch sind schwach normative Prädikate
und ganz klar normativ ist natürlich gut
und böse diese ganzen Kategorien mit
denen wir gewohnt sind unseren Alltag in
Angriff zu nehmen alle diese Kategorien
die greifen hier nicht sagte Autor weil
es sich ein Spiel handelt was nicht mal
mit der Antithese den Gegensatz von
Weisheit und Dummheit oder Spielerei
begriffen werden kann es hat einfach
seine eigenen Regeln seine eigene
handlungs Logik und das ist natürlich
ein Angebot und jetzt möchte ich sie so
früher Morgen natürlich aktivieren und
jetzt möchte ich Sie fragen gibt es
armoralischen Handlung oder überzeugt
sie das nicht selbst im Falle des Spiels
was sagen sie
also wir haben gesehen die Mehrheit sagt
es gibt amoralische Handlung die Frage
ist nur was ist eine amoralische
Handlung ja wir sind jetzt eingegangen
auf klassische Spiele wie Fußball wie
Schach sind dann aber auch noch auf die
Ästhetik auf die Kunst gekommen und
haben gesagt auch die Kunst hatten
Autonomie die sie nicht ohne weiteres
moralisch fassen lässt wenn sie sich
nicht gerade instrumentalisieren lässt
das natürlich ein Problem ist und wir
sind sogar auch noch auf die
Wissenschaft gekommen die natürlich auch
als eine Praxis verstanden werden kann
die gewisse Freiheiten hat
wissenschaftsfreiheiten die sich andere
Bereiche nicht erlauben dürfen die aber
natürlich auch ihre Grenzen hat sie die
Kommission und so weiter also sehr gute
Hinweise so heute geht es um moralische
Selbsttäuschung und auch da habe ich
jetzt wieder wie es für die Philosophie
üblich ist viele Fragen mehr Fragen als
Antworten welche Rolle spielt
Selbsttäuschung für unsere handeln
wie verhalten sich Gründe und
Selbsttäuschung zueinander wir hatten
schon auf Gründe hingewiesen wie
verhalten sich Rationalität und
Irrationalität zueinander wir müssen
natürlich auch noch die Frage nach der
Rationalität stellen oder nicht
Rationalität
und inwiefern können wir uns aus
Freiheit selbst täuschen sind wir für
unsere Selbsttäuschung verantwortlich am
Ende können wir zurechenbar auf
zurechenbare Weise uns täuschen was für
Interessen sollten wir eigentlich haben
uns zu täuschen ist Selbsttäuschung
schuldhaftes Selbsttäuschung nicht ein
Widerspruch in sich weil natürlich will
ich mich nicht täuschen ich will
natürlich wissen was der Fall ist wir
soll ich mich täuschen all das müssen
wir uns noch überlegen weil
Selbsttäuschung wie wir sehen werden
beim Handeln immer eine große Rolle
spielt
wo täuschen wir uns selbst wird immer
wieder konkret wo sollten wir uns denn
selbst im Handeln täuschen natürlich
dort wo ein heimliches peinliches oder
uneingestelltes Interesse herrscht dort
wo wir ein Interesse haben an etwas was
wir aber uns nicht eingestehen wollen
hier kommt wieder mein Beispiel der Neid
wir halten etwas ungerecht also der
maliziöse der bösartige Neid der
unmoralischenheit sind der Missgunst wir
halten etwas für ungerecht was
eigentlich gerecht ist und zwar deswegen
weil uns diese Auffassung dass etwas
ungerecht sein obwohl es gerecht ist
über unsere Unterlegenheit hinweg
tröstet also da haben wir natürlich ein
Interesse etwas für uns peinliches wie
zum Beispiel die Aussage dass wir
jemandem oder etwas unterlegen sind dass
wir schwächer sind das wird es uns nicht
eingestehen wollen wer tut es schon
gerne zu sagen ich bin schlecht oder
schlecht Herr als jemand anderes ja das
dazu gehört eine gewisse Größe eine
gewisse Tugend wenn man es mit aristotel
ist bezeichnen soll die Frage ist was zu
tun das ist Bescheidenheit
Ehrlichkeit vielleicht aber das fällt
uns einfach schwer in der Regel das
einzugestehen gerade dann wenn wir uns
wie in dieser modernen Gesellschaft
stets unter vergleichsdruck ausgesetzt
sehen wenn es um kompetitive Zustände
geht so neu sind diese kompetitiven
Zustände gar nicht sondern nur so den
wir auch mal kennengelernt hatten hat
gesagt wir leben im Vernunft Zustand
nicht mehr im Naturzustand im
Naturzustand ist natürlich ein Konstrukt
und ein Ideal im Naturzustand waren wir
uns gegenseitig in Mitleid und Liebe
zugetan das war aber keine eigennützige
Liebe sondern es war so eine eine
Selbstliebe die auch zugleich die Liebe
der anderen einschloss die war nicht
ausschließlich zu verstehen ihm Vernunft
Zustand dagegen sagt wo so da
vergleichen wir uns nur noch mit anderen
und bekommen unsere eigene Liebe nur
dadurch zustande dass wir und im
Vergleich zu anderen als überlegen
empfinden natürlich leiden wir auch
drunter wenn wir anderen uns als
unterlegen empfinden das heißt unsere
selbstverhältnisse werden im
vernunftzustand dadurch bedingt wie sich
unsere fremdverhältnisse gestalten ja
also wir beziehen sagen nur Selbstwert
aus dem Vergleich mit anderen und zwar
mittels unsere Vernunft deswegen spricht
so auch vom Vernunft Zustand und
natürlich wie Sie sich denken können
beurteilt und so den Vernunft Zustand
sehr negativ ja also Vernunft Zustand
kommen sehr viele Laster zu Tage sowas
wie natürliches Mitleid gibt's nicht
mehr im Vernunft Zustand da gilt nur
noch das rechte Stärken des vergleichen
und das heißt dieses Rechte stärken ist
gar nicht nach wo sowas was dem Natur
Zustand so gehört was man ja
normalerweise immer denken sollte
sondern nein dieser Vergleich der kommt
erst dann zustande wenn wir hier ist mit
Rationalität
zu tun haben das heißt dieser Gedanke
ist jetzt gar nicht so neu der ist
irgendwie leidend für die moderne
das heißt moralische Selbsttäuschung
auch moralische Selbsttäuschung ist
immer latent interessiert und motiviert
wir täuschen uns im Handeln in der Regel
oder in bestimmten Hinsichten nicht
einfach so das passiert natürlich auch
dass wir uns mal täuschen über etwas
klar ich täusche mich auch mal darüber
dass
ich weiß nicht die Klausur doch nicht so
schwer ist wie ich gedacht habe ja okay
da täuscht kann passieren aber in der
Regel oder in vielen interessanten
Fällen möchte ich mal sagen hat diese
Selbsttäuschung Gründe sie hat Gründe
wir können fragen warum haben wir uns
selbst getäuscht und die Gründe sind
häufig solche dass wir einfach
interessiert waren wir haben etwas
verfolgt etwas strapaziert was gar nicht
so hätte strapaziert werden soll und
warum haben wir etwas strapaziert weil
wir daran
vielleicht sogar uneingestandener Weise
interessiert sind ich würde es gerade
noch außen dann können wir darüber
diskutieren wenn wir jetzt akzeptieren
dass es so eine Form von Selbsttäuschung
gibt die immer an einer einer latenten
Interesse orientiert ist also die auf
Gründen basiert deren wir uns nicht so
bewusst sind oder von Konstellation von
Gründen abhängt die wir nicht
überschauen weil wir sie uns nicht
eingestehen wollen warum nicht weil das
für uns peinlich wäre weil wir schämen
wird und so weiter und so fort dann
setzt es aber voraus dass wir dazu auch
Vernunft benötigen nämlich um die Gründe
und so zurechtzulegen dass sie unserem
latenten heimlichen Interesse was wir
uns vielleicht gar nicht eingestehen
wollen entsprechend
Selbsttäuschung mit anderen Worten ist
also unserer freien aber endlich
Individualität von dir wir sind endlich
gewesen das bedeutet wir sind nicht
perfekte Wesen
wir sind aber obwohl wir endlich gewesen
sind natürlich freie Wesen das heißt wir
können das kann natürlich wieder
kritisieren ob ihr freiwesen sind aber
wir sind Wesen zumindest sagen dass 90
Prozent von ihnen die moralisch
zurechenbar sind für ihre Handlung und
dann kann man schon sagen warum kommen
wir dazu dass wir etwas Unmoralisches
zum Beispiel tun und das wäre jetzt eine
Antwort drauf wir sind keine perfekten
Wesen wir haben Schwächen wir haben
Ängste wir haben
Schamgefühle wir wollen uns schützen
weil wir verletzlich sind wir gestehen
uns das nicht zu wir trauen uns nicht
das offenzulegen haben aber Interessen
und haben natürlich auch Rationalität
und daraus folgt dann dass wir häufig
dazu geneigt sind und selbst zu täuschen
und darüber können wir jetzt natürlich
auch wieder ganz ganz treffend
diskutieren
können ja wir haben gesehen
Selbsttäuschung oder moralische
Selbsttäuschung scheint in vielen Fällen
vorzukommen die Frage ist gibt es Form
von Selbsttäuschung die nicht
zurechenbar sind die nicht fand für die
wir nicht verantwortlich sind hier kann
man viele das andere Beispiel anführen
wir gehen jetzt weiter weil dieses Thema
hängt mit dem Thema Irrationalität
zusammen also sind wir wenn wir uns
selbst täuschen und auch verantwortlich
zurechenbar selbst täuschen sind wir da
nicht im Grunde genommen irrational wie
können wir uns wenn es dieses Phänomen
gibt wenn wir damit übereinstimmt das
ist sowas wie moralische
selbstverschuldete Selbsttäuschung gibt
inwiefern ist es dann irrational zu
nehmen und sie nennen sich noch alle an
die Unterscheidung Moralität
Immoralität Amoralität ich habe schon
angedeutet die letzten Vorlesung das
gleiche können wir auch machen mit Blick
auf Rationalität also wir können sagen
es gibt Ration es gibt Irrationalität
und es gibt Irrationalität ja so wie wir
das machen können mit Blick auf die
Moral oder Moralität jetzt müssen wir
uns mal erstmal Gedanken machen was ist
eigentlich das Verhältnis von
Rationalität und Irrationalität und sie
ahnen es schon hier kommt natürlich
wieder Donald Davidson ins Spiel den sie
schon mal gehört haben als es um das
Thema der Willensschwäche ging
Willensschwäche war für Davidson ein
fast schon irrationales Phänomen ich bin
mir nicht mehr sicher ob es als
irrational bezeichnet hat das war
irgendwie ein Phänomen weiß ich nicht so
ganz erklären lässt und wir müssen
einfach uns eingestehen wenn wir hier
über praktische Philosophie reden das
ist auch Phänomene gibt die sich
irgendwie zu unserem
rationalitätsbegriff problematisch
Verhalten das müssen wir akzeptieren
solche möglichen Fälle die unsere
begriffslogik zu springen scheinen oder
Phänomen dafür müssen wir offen sein der
praktischen Philosophie nicht nur für
das Böse das Unmoral sind auch so für
Fälle wo man gar nicht mehr wirklich
vielleicht rational drüber sprechen kann
und dennoch müssen wir als Philosophen
und Philosophen rational über
Irrationalität sprechen das ist ein
Problem wie können wir auf
philosophische das heißt rationale Weise
über das Phänomen der Irrationalität
sprechen oder können wir darüber gar
nicht rational sprechen weil sie
irrational ist ja das ist die Frage und
jetzt sagt hier Donald Davidson im
ersten Zitat die Möglichkeit von
Irrationalität hängt zu einem hohen Grad
von Rationalität ab
Irrationalität ist nicht einfach ein
Mangel sondern eine Krankheit oder eine
Störung der von unerträgt noch ein Zitat
die Vorstellung von einer irrationalen
Handlung Überzeugung Absicht folgung
oder Gemütsbewegung ist paradox denn das
Irrationale ist nicht bloß das nicht
rationale das außerhalb des Bereichs des
rationalen liegt sondern Irrationalität
ist ein Versagen innerhalb des Hauses
der von uns okay jetzt bringt er
natürlich wieder eine Metapher bei Haus
der Vernunft vielleicht sogar eine
Allegorie ja wenn man so weiter
ausschmückt ich möchte noch ein Zitat
bringen und dann diskutieren wir darüber
Irrationalität tritt nur in Erscheinung
wenn Rationalität offensichtlich am
Platz ist nämlich dort wo sowohl Ursache
als auch Wirkung Inhalte haben die in
solchen logischen Beziehungen zueinander
stehen die der Vernunft Entgegenkommen
oder deren Scheitern begünstigen
Ereignisse die nur im Hinblick auf ihre
physikalischen oder physiologischen
Eigenschaften aufgefasst werden können
nicht zur beurteilt als seien sie Gründe
als stünden sie miteinander im
Widerstreit oder behandelten von einem
Thema und zum Schluss sagte
naturursachen und Blinde Kräfte gehören
nicht zur Kategorie des Irrationalen
sondern zur Kategorie des nicht
rationalen oder auch rational mit
unseren Begriffen und auch darüber
wollen wir jetzt mal kurz diskutieren
macht es überhaupt Sinn so von
Irrationalität zu sprechen dass sie
immer im Haus der Vernunft sich
vollzieht was soll man darunter
verstehen
ja wir haben gesehen dass Irrtum wenn
wir Donald Davidson Recht geben eine
gewisse Form von Rationalität
voraussetzen muss also wer irrtumsfähig
ist muss rational sein sondern dumitiere
wie man sich vorstellt irren eigentlich
nicht sondern Irrtum setzt voraus eine
Auffassung zu haben ein Urteil gefällt
zu haben was dann am Ende fallsifiziert
wird und zu einem solchen Urteil einer
Hypothese die man bilden kann die dann
eben auch zu führen kann brauchen wir
Vernunft in der letzten Sitzung in der
nächsten Sitzung geht's um praktische
Philosophie und Digitalität inwiefern
können wir in der virtuellen Realität
handeln was ist überhaupt virtuelle
Realität Metaversum und so weiter können
Roboter und künstliche intelligente
Systeme wie z.B Chat
kennt jeder hier handelt handeln wir
wenn wir Computerspiele spielen oder
simulieren wir nur aber auch Simulation
kann ja eine Handlung sein und zum
Schluss wie ist Computerspielen und
überhaupt spielen moralisch zu bewerten
wenn wir hier natürlich nicht an
expliziten Fokus auf dem
Moralphilosophie haben dann bedanke mich
für die Aufmerksamkeit bis zur nächsten
Woche